I guess I'm just gonna have to go for it
oh wow
oh wow wow nine out of ten
and minus three
[Music]
hey this is Chris Eubank Jr and this is
snack Wars on sport Bible
wow I knew this was coming here we have
the stupendous confectionery that is the
smarties I mean it's hard to beat in in
in the states Smarties are not are
different they're like candy and they
this they've just ruined it you know I
grew up on these back in back when I was
a kid they used to be in this little
tube and used to pop the lid open I used
to just kill or kill these very very
very good confectionery stupendous and
the famous Hershey bar I've had many of
these I haven't tried cookies and creams
uh wait cookies and chocolate okay yeah
I haven't tried this one so let's find
out
good
I am now a new fan I have to keep all
this stuff away from me in the house
because otherwise I won't make weight
see I've got to find
this is the one right here this is the
winner if they if they ever made just a
tube of orange Smarties I would buy
those every time
incredible so stupendous
for me yeah you can't you can't even
compare the two Smarties stupendous can
fact for me every day of the week I can
smell this already I think it's good
okay here we go now we got the good
stuff the classic
sausage and egg McMuffin I mean I grew
up in this stuff it's hard to beat it
really is hard to beat the American
version
is terrible and it tastes different the
English ones are so much better this is
great
[Applause]
I mean as far as breakfast sandwiches go
this is a nine wow this is this is
special to bring back the memories you
know as a kid
going to McDonald's for breakfast but
they've always always tasted the same
you know now we are going for I think as
a pork pie
that's not a pork pie is this a pork pie
that's a pork and pickle pie wow how did
the pickle you ruined it
you shouldn't ever have any Sweetness in
a pork pie terrible I know America wins
that one for sure
oh no you haven't you haven't done it I
mean this is just so disrespectful to
British culture you know cheese it's one
of my favorite foods I can put cheese on
anything there's not a meal you can name
that I couldn't add cheese on it it'll
make it taste better and the Americans
they found a way to just I mean put it
in a can and spray it I've always
refused to try it because it's just like
I I like expensive mature cheddar cheese
I'm worried I'm actually a little bit
afraid to try this because you know I
don't know what to expect I mean this is
great we've got the classic British
cheese
and crackers a beautiful snack onion
Chutney sounds wonderful I'm trying to
think which one I should have but that's
going to ruin my day so
I'm probably gonna have this one first
and then dry on that out with with the
good stuff so how does this even work
you just
oh wow look at that I guess I'm just
gonna have to go for it
oh wow wow
so bad
now we're going to get to the proper
stuff here
so what I usually do how I eat cheese
and crackers is a bit in the Chutney
first
so I I go back and forth so I take a
bite
no
you can't beat that you know nine out of
ten and minus three
sorry if you want to just put your hand
forward a bit okay
put your hand forward here I'm gonna pop
it on the top of a bit there you go what
are we doing here okay
[Laughter]
let's see how well you guys have made
these crumpets
foreign
hasn't been overcooked or undercooked
it's a skill some people some people go
one way or the other but this is is done
perfectly so yeah now we've got the
Fruit Loops
I don't know about you guys but
whenever I eat cereal
I have to have a
a lot of milk have you not got any other
milk this is so bad I can't believe I'm
doing this I've never ever poured myself
a bowl of cereal with skim milk I guess
is the first time for everything
I do this thing where I have to make
show every bit of cereal is covered by
the milk first
and I have to let it soak for about a
minute I understand we're on a time
schedule here so I'm just going to jump
straight in thank you I really
appreciate it my heart went when you
said that
this is the thing I do it's weird yeah I
soak the cereal this is this is actually
turned the colors have turned the milk
um blue which is interesting let's see
foreign
I'm a big Honey Nut Cheerio fan and this
has got some like fruit flavors to it
which are different not for me crumpets
over over Fruit Loops all day of the
week
hmm
I commentated on ksi's fight a few weeks
ago and I was with Logan
uh also and he you know we took a
picture and he you know he put his arm
around me he had his you know the prime
he's incredible the marketing the
marketing this guy has the you know he
had the the Prime in his hand I didn't
realize until I saw the picture later on
um but yeah this is I guess the the new
drink
it's come out now KSI Logan Paul I
haven't tried it yet so that's
interesting and here we have yeah I grew
up on lucozade the original two so much
better than the orange I know that
there's a whole bunch of different
flavors now but you you can't beat the
original
you know there's no other drink that
tastes like this on the planet and I've
drank hard drinks everywhere there's
just a very unique taste and I I love it
but this is the one I haven't tried
lemon and lime Prime
and Shake
it's apparently these are sold out
everywhere I don't know how a drink
sells out but
I don't know it's uh it's very sweet it
says naturally flavored I mean the balls
these guys have to put that on this
street there's nothing natural about
this it doesn't taste bad but it's you
know it's definitely uh it's not a
natural flavor of drink 10 coconut water
okay that's cool UK wins lucozade very
hard to beat the UK has won
hey there was never any doubt you know
UK versus us we had to we had to pull
the victory out the back you're not
supposed to go and lift weights and come
out and go hmm do a lot of protein snack
past me to Pork scratches oh yeah if one
of the fighters fighting one of your
cards was eating them pre-fight would
you be saying I mean can you imagine
it's like he's in the hotel lobby and I
walk over all right man we've got there
I'll go pork scratches